so we Shot the movie in Bulgaria we
built we've literally built the entire
neighborhood and I mean built it like
for real like real structures with
Windows and Doors it was amazing all the
Kid cast comes back to my brother and
all the actual actors playing them which
was phenomenal which was another reason
like another sort of box I wanted to
check to to do this
um Scott Farkas the bully um Grover Dill
his Toady um flicking Schwartz and Randy
all come back dude how surreal was that
the first day when you were on your
network
and I looked around I'm like oh my God
just we all had this moment like man
we're back like this world is recreated
and we're in it and for them you know I
had been working on it for a while but I
asked them how they felt and they said
it was shockingly more emotional and I
think you really you really feel the
friendships and the connections it feels
like kind of like when you go home you
know it's about Ralphie going home he
goes back to the old neighborhood and he
lives in Chicago he lives in a big city
trying to make his bones and it's not
going well for him
[Music]
you feel that
you know and it was cool to to imagine
okay where where are these guys now 30
odd years later